in der rüdes sevre 40 im Herzen von
Paris befindet sich der Hauptsitz von
kehring dem Luxus Giganten zudem neben
Goji als Hauptmarke auch
yvesa und Balenciaga gehören ein
Meisterwerk von 1600 mit Garten einem
17.000 Quadratmeter großen Gebäude und
einer Kirche im Inneren der Gucci Happ
befindet sich in der Via mitschenate 79
in Mailand
35.000 Quadratmeter in einer ehemaligen
restaurierten Flugzeugfabrik es umfasst
einen sechsstöckigen Turm für Büros und
Designer einen Showroom einen Raum für
Modeschauen und auch einen lindenwald
aber in der Via industria 19 in
kadempino in diesem anonymen Gebäude
zwischen der Autobahn und dem
Tennisplatz werden 80% der Gewinne der
gesamten clearing-gruppe erzählt ein
nett von 1,7 Milliarden Franken im Jahr
greetings and welcome to another
wonderful day in a good
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nachdem Gucci 20 Jahre lang über die lgi
in ktempino Steuern im Tessin gezahlt
hat hat das Unternehmen das zur
kehring-gruppe gehört das Finanzamt in
den Ländern zurückerobert in denen die
Arbeiter den Reichtum produzieren dieses
Jahr verlässt der größte Steuerzahler
den
kantona
hat dies bestätigt ihr machte das was
alle Gucci nennen jährlich 3/4 der
Steuereinnahmen aus
[Musik]
was genau hat ihnen lgi im Dezember wenn
ich mich nicht irre gesagt
es war noch November sie teilten uns mit
dass wir aufgrund einer Änderung in
Ihrem Unternehmen in den nächsten Jahren
weniger Steuern erhalten würden
im Jahr 2019
80% weniger als ihr üblicher Standard
und ab 2020 dann 95% weniger
5% der Einnahmen die bisher von lgi
bezahlt wurden
wird in der Schweiz deutlich weniger
Steuern zahlen und hat bereits
angekündigt vorerst 150 Mitarbeiter zu
versetzen kadempino wird jedes Jahr 8
Millionen Franken verlieren der Kanton
sogar mehr als 20
genau
hier ist der Platz mit den Steinen
Granit oder was weiß ich und drumherum
wird die Bepflanzung sein einschließlich
etwaiger Dekoration des Platzes Pflanzen
und andere Dinge
mit 1.500 Einwohnern bis heute die
reichste Stadt des Tessins ist das
Symbol für die enormen Einnahmen die der
luxusriese jährlich garantiert mit
diesem Geld werden das neue Gemeindehaus
und der Platz fertiggestellt eine
Investition von rund 10 Millionen
Franken
[Musik]
es ist wirklich groß war es eine
ungewöhnliche Investition für eine Stadt
mit 1.500 Einwohnern
das sind große Räume die Platz für
Entwicklung bieten
sie den Wegfall der Einnahmen aus ihren
wirtschaftlichen Ressourcen
nun ein bisschen verändert
früher waren wir Onkel Dagobert es war
nur so weil wir Glück hatten und wir
Administrator wir haben die mittelgut
verwaltet und können sicherlich die
nächsten fünf Jahre ohne Probleme
weitermachen
in diesen Jahren hat cadempino 30
Millionen Franken beiseite gelegt die
ist der Gemeinde nun ermöglichen das
Schlimmste zu verhindern
[Musik]
muss ich sagen eine kalte Dusche nicht
nur für die Gemeinde sondern auch für
den Kanton und folglich auch auf
Bundesebene und ich denke wir haben kein
Recht uns aus irgendeinem Grund zu
beschweren
Umsatzrückgang bei lgi worauf ist der
zurückzuführen
auf die Umstrukturierung die Sie
innerhalb des Unternehmens hatten das
ist die Veränderung die Beziehungen die
wir hatten sind gut
wir sollten hier diskretionen denn das
Unternehmen selbst hat auch immer
Diskretion waren lassen
heute wird jedoch gegen den Konzern von
der Staatsanwaltschaft Mailand ermittelt
wonach er gerade über die Tessiner
Niederlassung lgi luxre goods
international se zwischen 2011 und 2017
Steuern in Höhe von 1,4 Milliarden Euro
hinterzogen und Einnahmen in Höhe von
14,5 Milliarden Euro nicht deklariert
haben soll
sie wegen Steuerhinterziehung ermittelt
wird von dem Unternehmen bei ihrem
Treffen erwähnt
nein wir wir haben nicht über
Untersuchungen gesprochen auch weil es
nicht an uns liegt zu wissen oder nicht
zu wissen warum gegen sie ermittelt wird
wenn gegen sie ermittelt wird
aber wir haben von den Zinsen profitiert
die sie uns gegeben haben und das ist
genug für uns ich persönlich habe nicht
zu beanstanden
es tut mir leid dass dieses Geld
woanders hingeht aber solange sie hier
waren hat sich niemand beschwert denn es
gab nur einen Verlust zu verzeichnen
auf kantonaler Ebene bei den Steuern
haben Sie sich jemals gefragt wie ein
Unternehmen wie lgi so viele Gewinne in
cadantino erzählen konnte
erzielt haben
der lgi-hauptsitz in kadempino
erwirtschaftete 2017 einen Reingewinn
von fast 1,7 Milliarden Franken zum
Vergleich das ist ein höherer Gewinn als
bei Swisscom und doppelt so hoch wie bei
Swatch wie wir bereits in einem Bericht
von vor zwei Jahren aufzeigten hat lgi
mit nur 800 Angestellten im Vergleich zu
den 30.000 Angestellten im Rest der Welt
seit Jahren den größten Teil der
Gewinner des multinationalen
luxuskonzerns Gehring in der Schweiz
konzentriert wo er eine privilegierte
kantonale Besteuerung von 8% genießt ein
äußerst wettbewerbsfähiger Satz im
Vergleich zu den Steuern im Rest der
Welt
was war die Funktion der lgi die diese
stratosphärischen gewinnerechtfertigte
eine Quelle die der Spitze des
Unternehmens sehr nahe steht hat mit uns
gesprochen wir durften weder sein
Gesicht Filmen noch Details über ihn
preisgeben wir konnten lediglich unsere
Gespräche aufzeichnen und nun davon
berichten Hering erklärt dass die
Tessiner Niederlassung kommerzielle
Tätigkeiten ausübte aber was geschah
wirklich in der lgi
es gab große Büros in denen den ganzen
Tag über Rechnungen gedruckt wurden mehr
nicht in der Schweiz wurden nur
logistische und buchhalterische Aufgaben
wahrgenommen
auf keinen Fall es gibt überhaupt keine
es gibt nichts kein Käufer ist jemals in
cadantino gewesen
haben sie gerade Pino gesehen glauben
sie kann im Pino repräsentiert die Marke
ich meine es ist ein Lagerhaus ein
Hangar der Verkauf von Gucci findet in
Mailand statt
Hering erklärte aber dass lgi eine
kommerzielle Plattform sei
ze ich habe nie gesehen dass bei lgi
gehandelt wurde es gab eine
institutionalisierte Falschdarstellung
dessen was lgi für Steuerzwecke Tat eine
Art betrug
warum verlässt die karin-gruppe das
Tessin wir haben sie ihren Weggang
begründet
und nur die Steuern mit dem Wegfall der
Steuervergünstigungen seitdem die
italienische Staatsanwaltschaft gegen
sie wegen Steuerhinterziehung ermittelt
ergibt der Verbleib im Tessin keinen
Sinn mehr denn der würde nur
betriebliche Ineffizienz und einen
Anstieg der Kosten bedeuten
ihre Mitarbeiter bereits über die
Verlagerung nach Italien insbesondere
nach Novara informiert ein
Logistikzentrum und ein Werk besitzt das
bereits erweitert wird über seine
eigenen Entscheidungen bewahrt das
Unternehmen äußerste Diskretion aber es
ist uns gelungen mit einigen
Mitarbeitern zu sprechen auch in diesem
Fall wird niemand zu erkennen sein
das einzige was Sie von einem wollen ist
wir mussten eine
Geheimhaltungsverpflichtung
unterschreiben sie wollen nicht dass
jemand darüber spricht es geht das
Gerücht um dass sie bald mit allem
umziehen werden bei lgi sind die
Gehälter im Vergleich zu den
schweizerischen Standards viel niedriger
sie liegen zwischen 3.400 und 3.800
Franken pro Monat wenn man bereits etwas
Erfahrung hat für die Versetzung nach
Italien wurde dasselbe Gehalt
vorgeschlagen allerdings mit
italienischer Besteuerung das heißt 40%
weniger
für diejenigen die bereits in Italien
leben also fast alle in der Firma ist
das in Ordnung aber die wenigen
Schweizer die dort arbeiten wurden in
die Knie gezwungen
dort irgendwelche kommerziellen
Aktivitäten durchgeführt oder wichtige
Entscheidungen getroffen nein
das war eine rein logistische und
buchhalterische Angelegenheit der Rest
ist in kallepin nur sicher nie passiert
der normale wir wussten irgendwie dass
es für lgi einen etwas fadenscheinigen
Grund gab in der Schweiz zu sein
zum Beispiel werden in cadempino
Etiketten gedruckt und an die
Lieferanten geschickt man hat uns immer
gesagt dass wir das tun müssen um zu
zeigen dass wir dort an der Produktion
beteiligt sind
meinen sie die Etiketten die in die
Kleidung eingenäht sind genau aber sie
sagten sie müssten in der Schweiz
gemacht werden und das war's haben die
Arbeiter gemacht nein nein früher haben
wir das gemacht sie die Büroangestellten
ja wir haben uns abgewechselt um uns um
diese Dinge zu kümmern
aber die Steuern werden dort bezahlt wo
die Hauptaktivitäten stattfinden wie
konnten sie rechtfertigen dass eine
reine logistik-niederlassung in
kadempino Gewinne in Höhe von 1,7
Milliarden Franken erwirtschaftet diese
Frage scheint bei Gucci im Mittelpunkt
der Überlegungen gestanden zu haben denn
je größer sie wurde desto mehr musste
sie rechtfertigen das wertschöpfende
Tätigkeiten in der Tessiner
Niederlassung durchgeführt wurden wo sie
steuern zeigte die Lösung eine Liste von
22 Managern die offenbar im Tessin
Arbeiten und Wohnen
es gab Direktoren die sich als unsere
manager-ausgaben obwohl sie es in
Wirklichkeit nicht waren sie schienen
ein Büro in kadem Kino zu haben aber wir
haben sie nie gesehen die wichtigen
Männer waren sicherlich nicht in
calimpino tatsächlich wurden ihre Büros
als Besprechungsräume genutzt weil jeder
wusste dass sie nie da waren okay
sie hatten einen gefälschten Wohnsitz um
einen Beweis dafür zu liefern das
wichtige Führungsaufgaben in der Schweiz
wahrgenommen wurden gleichzeitig stellte
die Gruppe diesen Managern
bürosekretariat der organisatorische und
operative Unterstützung in Italien zur
Verfügung
in Italien
sehr selten fast nie
haben Sie jemals wirklich in diesen
Wohnungen gelebt
sie haben nie dort gewohnt die
Wohnungsverwaltung wurde den
Angestellten überlassen einige
Assistenten wurden geschickt um von Zeit
zu Zeit die Post abzuholen und die
Stromzähler zu kontrollieren indem sie
ab und zu das Licht einschalteten und
die Waschmaschinen laufen ließen damit
der Stromverbrauch glaubwürdiger war
Elektriker
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie Sie aus dieser internen E-Mail
ersehen können hat kehring selbst die
Versetzungen in die Schweiz vorbereitet
und zwar nicht für irgendwelche stellen
sondern für Schlüsselpositionen im
Unternehmen zum Beispiel Robert trifus
Leiter des Marketings Diana zanetto
Leiterin des Merchandising Fabio JUSO
stellvertretender Leiter des
Einzelhandels und mehr Leiter der
Personalabteilung Leitern der
Schuhabteilung die Liste ist lang nach
unseren Informationen hat praktisch
keiner von ihnen jemals einen Fuß ins
Tessin gesetzt für zwei Personen ist
jedoch eine Sonderbehandlung reserviert
die beiden höchsten Gucci
Spitzenpositionen Patricio di Marco und
Marco bizari
zu unserer Rettung haben wir einige sehr
interessante und exklusive Dokumente
erhalten es handelt sich um dieselben
Dokumente die Mediapart erhalten und mit
einem Konsortium von
Enthüllungsjournalisten geteilt hat
Patricio de Marco der bis 2014 im Amt
war war offenbar in der Schweiz ansässig
wo er eine pauschalsteuerregelung genoss
mit dem Mietvertrag in der Hand sehen
wir uns an wo der gucci-präsident wohnte
[Musik]
wissen Sie ob Patricia Uni Marco hier
gewohnt hat
ich kenne ihn nicht der CEO von Gucci
haben sie ihn jemals hier gesehen die
Marco nein darf ich Ihnen ein Bild
zeigen damit Sie mir sagen können ob sie
ihnen jemals gesehen haben ja wie lange
leben sie schon hier vier Jahre vier
Jahre okay ja diese Person kennen Sie
sie haben sie ihn jemals gesehen
tut mir leid ich kenne ihn nicht
leben sie schon lange hier ja mindestens
vier oder fünf Jahre
wenn ich Ihnen ein Bild zeige haben sie
ihn vielleicht schon mal hier gesehen
auf keinen Fall sie haben ihn nie
gesehen
[Musik]
Faktor in die sie kommen kostet die
Wohnung neben meiner ist leer seit ich
hier bin es steht also schon seit vier
Jahren leer auf jeden Fall ja
die Marco wurde hier nie gesehen allein
die Prämie für Kleidung die die Marco
von der Firma erhielt war höher als die
Jahresmiete dieser Wohnung kann man
wirklich glauben dass der Präsident von
Gucci mit seinem Jahresumsatz von
mehreren Millionen eine 3.600 Franken
Wohnung im ersten Stock mit Blick auf
die Bahn angemietet hatte
[Musik]
nun 1500 Quadratmeter 44 Zimmer 5 Etagen
die sich über drei Hausnummern
erstrecken mit der Adresse in der Hand
erreichen wir eine andere Art von
Aussicht auf die die Fenster von wie
Marco blicken
[Musik]
wer ist da guten Morgen Ich wollte
fragen ob es möglich ist mit Herrn
Patrizio di Marco zu sprechen
wer fragt ich bin Anna Bernasconi wir
arbeiten für das Schweizer Fernsehen
ja nein denn er ist nicht da
er ist nicht zu Hause nein er ist nicht
zu Hause die Marco scheint mit seiner
Tochter und seiner Frau in dieser Villa
auf dem jannikulo in einem der
angesehensten Viertel Roms zu wohnen
Frieda janini die berühmte ehemalige
Designerin von Gucci stand tatsächlich
am Fenster
ich habe mich gefragt ob es möglich ist
mit Herrn die Marco zu sprechen er ist
nicht zu Hause er ist nicht zu Hause ich
wollte ihnen um einige Informationen
bitten über laufende Ermittlungen
ich weiß davon nichts ich werde mit
meinem Mann darüber sprechen
ich wollte etwas über seinen Wohnsitz in
der Schweiz erfahren
er ist in Italien ansässig
gegenwärtig aber früher war er in der
Schweiz ansässig hören Sie ich rufe Sie
zurück
das ist die Information die ich haben
wollte
okay danke
[Musik]
dasselbe gilt auch für Marco bizarri den
derzeitigen Vorsitzenden der Gruppe
Pauschalpreis Wohnsitz in wiko Morcote
wohin er jedoch nie einen Fuß gesetzt zu
haben scheint
[Musik]
ist das nicht der Typ der ganz oben
wohnt den schon mal jemand gesucht hat
sicherlich haben schon andere
Journalisten nach ihm gesucht es ist
schon jemand aus Italien gekommen um ihn
zu suchen aber ich habe ihn nie gesehen
was wäre wenn ich Ihnen ein Bild zeigen
würde warten sie kurz ich komme
ich habe nie gesehen ich sehe ihn da
jetzt auf dem Foto aber nein ich kann
Ihnen nicht helfen wie lange leben sie
schon in diesem Haus 38 Jahre 38 Jahre
genau hier ich hätte ihn sehen müssen
zumindest im Auto genau aber das der CEO
von Gucci genau hier gewohnt haben soll
nein nein das haben sie auch nicht
gewusst ich habe nie gesehen nein
sowohl gegen bizzari als auch gegen die
Marco wird von der Staatsanwaltschaft
Mailand ermittelt bizzari arbeitet und
lebt in Mailand und zwar seit Jahren im
Dachgeschoss eines der exklusivsten
Gebäude hinter der piazadora ich werde
Ihnen ein Bild zeigen
kennen sie ihn kommt er hierher um
Kaffee zu trinken da kann man ein paar
mal vorbei ja
er wohnt hier
[Musik]
hallo ich habe bizari nie im lgi gesehen
zumindest soweit ich weiß pizzari sagen
wir mal er ist leicht zu erkennen sie
haben ihn noch nie gesehen nein ich habe
ihn nie gesehen und ich habe noch nie
Kollegen sagen hören dass sie bizarre
gesehen haben
Patricio de Marco nein auch nicht
die Marco ibizari sie sono President die
Marco und Pizzaria haben den
Steuervorteil genutzt und sind nie nach
keinem Pino gekommen nun das Management
das sind die Funktionen mit Mehrwert sie
sollten in der Schweiz bleiben und ihre
Aufgaben dort erfüllen so dass die Marge
in der Schweiz korrekt zugewiesen wurde
damit
welche Überprüfungen wurden durchgeführt
als man den beiden supermanagern die
Marco und bizari das globalistische
Regime gewährte hat man nie eine
Unregelmäßigkeit in Bezug auf die
Herkunft ihrer Einkünfte bemerkt die
beitragsabteilung lehnte ein Interview
diesbezüglich ab und berief sich in
einer schriftlichen Erklärung auf das
Steuergeheimnis
soviel ich weiß haben die Behörden das
nie überprüft ja die Wahrheit ist dass
das einfach niemand kontrolliert hat
[Musik]
und wie wurde die Marke bezahlt es gibt
neue vertrauliche Dokumente die
ehemalige Nummer eins von Gucci erhielt
demnach zusätzlich zu ihrem regulären
Gehalt in Italien eine zweite Vergütung
als Berater diese Vergütung wurde im
ersten Jahr von der lgi in cadempino
gezeigt bis die Marco im Jahr 2010 die
Globalisierung in der Schweiz beantragte
allerdings darf man kein Schweizer
Einkommen haben wenn man diese
Steuervorteile erhalten will wie konnte
das Problem gelöst werden ganz einfach
durch die Übertragung des
Beratervertrags von der Tessiner lgi auf
eine gewisse Castella ein Unternehmen
mit Sitz in Luxemburg eine inoffizielle
Vergütung die über eine ihrer
Offshore-Gesellschaften in Panama wenn
die international mit einem Konto in
Singapur erzielt wurde es gibt nur
wenige Zweifel daran dass die doppelten
Verträge der reguläre in Italien und
dieser Beratungsvertrag mit dem
luxemburgischen unternehmen castera
nichts weiter waren als ein Spielchen um
einen großen Teil der Vergütung unter
der Hand sein zu können die beiden
Verträge wurden am selben Tag
unterzeichnet die bonusmitteilungen
wurden immer zu denselben Terminen
verschickt und von demselben Präsidenten
von kehring Pino unterzeichnet das wurde
sogar von die Marco zum Zeitpunkt der
Unterbrechung seiner Geschäftsbeziehung
mit der Gruppe bestätigt in der er den
Vertrag mit Castella in Bezug auf
dieselbe und einzige Geschäftsbeziehung
definiert
[Musik]
nur vier Jahren zwischen 2010 und 2014
wurden von castera nach Panama monatlich
Überweisungen in Höhe von insgesamt 24
Millionen Franken getätigt und zwar
steuerfrei in der Schweiz kam die Marco
in den Genuss einer minimalen
Pauschalsteuer von 130.000 Franken das
heißt er zahlte nur 2% Steuern auf sein
tatsächliches Einkommen das ist 20 mal
weniger als er in Italien hätte zahlen
müssen dasselbe gilt für bizari bei
einer jährlichen Nettovergütung von 8
Millionen entgingen 6 Millionen Steuern
durch Luxemburg alles in allem liegt der
Vorteil dieses komplexen verdeckten
Zahlungssystems jedoch bei kehring
selbst das seinen Präsidenten dreimal
weniger zahlen konnte als sie
tatsächlich kosteten z.B für die 24
Millionen die an die Marco in Panama
gingen hätte sie 63 Millionen mit
Steuern zahlen müssen eine beträchtliche
Ersparnis und eine Möglichkeit die
besten Manager einzustellen
wir sind auf dem Weg nach Luxemburg
einer Steueroase im Herzen Europas wo
das Gesetz keine Steuern auf im Ausland
erwirtschaftete Einkünfte vorsieht Julia
Petrus 124
casteder hat die gleiche Adresse wie ein
viel wichtigeres Unternehmen caring
Luxemburg sa die Muttergesellschaft die
unter anderem den lukrativsten Zweig der
Gruppe kontrolliert die Tessiner lgi LG
ein Unternehmen mit hunderten von Aktien
und Milliarden von Dividenden hat seinen
Sitz bei dieser Firma die bereits voll
ausgestattete Büros vermietet
ist es möglich mit jemandem von kehring
oder casteder zu sprechen
es ist niemand da
niemand ist hier okay darf ich Sie
fragen wie viele Personen in ihren Büros
arbeiten
ohne ihre Genehmigung kann ich keine
Auskunft geben Informationen
wer ist der Direktor des Unternehmens
gibt es einen Leiter für die beiden
Büros
ohne Genehmigung kann ich keine weiteren
Auskünfte erteilen sie können keine
Auskunft geben
sie lassen uns nicht hinein aber nach
dem Grundriss zu urteilen den uns eine
Quelle innerhalb der Gruppe gegeben hat
scheint es sich hierbei ohnehin eher um
eine leere Box zu handeln
[Musik]
sie hatten weder Angestellte noch ein
richtiges Büro es war eine anormale
Sache ein legaler Kasten der Milliarden
pumpt und mehr nicht
wir versuchen die Adresse des einzigen
luxemburgischen Verwalters ausfindig zu
machen der sowohl bei castera als auch
bei kehring Luxemburg auftaucht
[Musik]
aber das ist alles was wir finden
konnten nur ein Briefkasten
sie sind Herr Ackermann
ja
erren Sie persönlich und direkt an der
Unterstützung und Verschleierung der
steuerposition von Herrn die Marko
beteiligt
ich will nicht mit ihnen reden so wie
bei Bizzarri
[Musik]
caring Luxemburg stützt sein
Steuersystem auf die
tessiner-niederlassung der lgi castera
dient der diskreten Entlohnung von
Managern die als Globalisten im Tessin
keine Einkünfte in der Schweiz beziehen
können es scheint ein Gesamtpaket zu
sein das kehring angeboten wird um so
viel wie möglich zu sparen und das mit
dem Tessin verflochten ist
wo wurde eigentlich das Konto der
luxemburgischen Gesellschaft eröffnet
und eingerichtet
die luxemburgische Firma castera
benutzte ein Konto der Credit Suisse den
Lugano das Geld kam von der lgi
Luxemburg war so strukturiert dass es
der Schweiz die Stirn bieten konnte der
steuerfuchs sitzt im Tessin
gehen wir zurück in die Tessiner Sonne
im Folgenden dürfen wir seine Stimme
zwar nicht preisgeben aber wir können
die Dialoge genauso wiedergeben wie sie
stattgefunden haben ein direkter Zeuge
der bisher noch nie gesprochen hat hat
sich bereit erklärt sich mit uns zu
treffen und uns zu verraten wie die
steuerarchitektur des Unternehmens in
der Schweiz aufgebaut und umgesetzt
wurde
wenn man der erste Steuerzahler des
Kantons ist eine bekannte Marke dann
erlaubt einen sein Status Dinge die
andere nicht erlaubt sind wenn man einen
Gast in der Kaiser Suite im Hotel hat
verwöhnt man ihn nicht wahr nun sie
waren Gäste in der Kaiser Suite sie
wurden verwöhnte und man hörte ihnen zu
die Person die die steuerlichen
Positionen der Gucci Manager und die
steuerstruktur des Unternehmens
aufgebaut hat ist ein Treuhänder mit
einem Büro in Lugano vom ersten Tag an
im Verwaltungsrat von Gucci in cadempino
Register
Systems für die Manager war adilio Lady
um die Tatsache zu umgehen dass die
globalistische Pauschalregelung durch
den Nachweis von auslandseinkünften
erreicht wird hat Lady das System in
Luxemburg ausgeheckt damit die Manager
die Marco und pizari jeweils der
globalistischen Regelung nach weniger
Steuern zahlen konnten er war persönlich
an der erlang um dieser
pauschalsteuerregelung für die beiden
CEOs beteiligt ja Lady ist das große
Gehirn der Strukturen der Schweiz und
bei all dem war Gucci definitiv der
größte Kunde der Firma
der Treuhänder antwortete uns auch nach
mehrmaligem Nachfragen nicht selbst wenn
wir persönlich in sein Büro gingen wurde
uns gesagt wir sollten unsere Fragen an
das französische Büro von
kehring-stellen
wie kam Gucci ursprünglich nach
cadantino
gucciino
damals Finanzdirektor der Gucci Gruppe
hatten bei Coopers und libron
zusammengearbeitet und waren durch eine
tiefe Freundschaft verbunden Lady war
gemeindevertreternino
Unternehmen der kehring-gruppe rund
250.000 Franken pro Jahr in Rechnung er
war aber auch teilzeitangestellter der
kehring Luxemburg financial investments
Niederlassung mit einem Festgehalt von
130000 Franken im Jahr bei LG i was also
praktisch einen zusätzlichen Mitarbeiter
auf der Lohnliste zu haben noch dazu
einen Schweizer um das Unternehmen
glaubwürdig zu machen um den Anschein
einer Schweizer Mehrheit in den
Verwaltungsräten zu erwecken wurden
weitere in der Schweiz ansässige
Personen eingestellt darunter mehrere
Berater
neben lgi taucht der Name des Tessiner
Treuhänders auch in den Aufsichtsräten
mehrerer Tessiner Modeunternehmen wie
Abercrombie Tom Ford und loropiana auf
die Firma war auch an der Gesellschaft
beteiligt die Ishikawa besitzt eine
Schuhmarke die von den italienischen
Finanzbehörden wegen Steuerhinterziehung
beschlagnahmt wurde mit einem Eigentümer
der einen scheinwohnsitz im Tessin hatte
und im lgi Verwaltungsrat saß seit der
Ankunft von Gucci im Tessin auch der
Berater Paolo brenni er ist Mitarbeiter
der Anwaltskanzlei masoni und Schwager
von Marina massoni Staatsrätin und
Direktorin des Wirtschafts- und
Finanzministeriums zur Zeit der
Ansiedlung von Gucci im Tessin und heute
Präsident von Ticino Mode die
Führungskräfte von Gucci und die gesamte
Gruppe die im Laufe der Jahre ein und
ausgegangen ist kamen alle bei der Firma
masoni vorbei um ihre Unterschrift zu
leisten alle Urkunden und
Rechtsberatungen wurden dort
durchgeführt
[Musik]
wir haben einen interessanten Austausch
von internen E-Mails erhalten die unter
den Top-Managern von kehring einem der
wichtigsten börsennotierten Unternehmen
in Frankreich verschickt wurden es wird
geschätzt dass sich die über die
Tessiner Niederlassung begangene
Steuerhinterziehung auf 2,5 Milliarden
Euro beläuft der größte Fall von
Steuerbetrug eines Unternehmens in
Frankreich jemals was die Hering
Direktorin in Aufruhr versetzt ist eine
Frage des französischen Senats der 2012
und 2013 zweimal wegen
Steuerhinterziehung ermittelt hat
bezahlt das Unternehmen Mitarbeiter im
Ausland wo sie keine Tätigkeiten ausüben
seien Sie vorsichtig schrieben sie und
versuchten dann in mehreren Anläufen
sich auf eine möglichst unkonkrete
Formel zu einigen um den Senat damit von
ihrer Ehrlichkeit zu überzeugen
tatsächlich hat kehring das für die
Bezahlung der Manager eingerichtete
offshore-system verschwiegen und zweimal
falsche Angaben gemacht Verfasser des
Fragebogens ist der Senator der
französischen Republik Erik Bouquet
Leiter der Untersuchungsausschüsse zur
Steuerhinterziehung
[Musik]
Gruppe der Familie Pino hat den Senat
zweimal belogen ich möchte Ihnen einige
Dokumente und E-Mails zeigen die einige
kehring Führungskräfte Palü und du play
geschrieben haben die sich an Sie wenden
auf Ihre Anfrage
seien sie auf der Hut saubere Version
der Antwort auf den senatsfragebogen das
ist unglaublich es ist ernst das
Parlament kann nicht bis zu diesem
Zeitpunkt verachtet werden das ist
absolut inakzeptabel der Senat kann in
dieser Angelegenheit nicht schweigen und
wenn es ein nachspielt gibt dann muss es
durch die Justiz gehen
steuerhinterziehung ist schwerwiegend
weil sie den Staatshaushalt gefährdet
das Geld wird in Schulen Krankenhäusern
Gemeinden dem was die Gesellschaft
verbessern würde vorenthalten man sagt
uns dass kein Geld da sei und das ist
große Gruppen wie diese gibt die
Frankreich jedes Jahr 80 Milliarden Euro
verlieren ließen
normaler France 80 Milliarden ist das
jährliche Defizit unseres Landes das ist
völlig inakzeptabel es gefährdet unsere
Gesellschaft es gefährdet die
Solidarität auch die Demokratie es sind
nicht die Konzerne die das Steuergesetz
machen es ist das Parlament es ist die
Politik mit einem großen P die über das
Steuerrecht entscheidet diese großen
Konzerne werden morgen die weltanführen
indem Sie sich dafür entscheiden dort
Steuern zu zahlen wo Sie wollen und
natürlich dort wo es viel billiger ist
das ist definitiv inakzeptabel ein
Unternehmen ist Teil der Gesellschaft es
ist ein Element es ist dazu da
Bedürfnisse zu befriedigen Waren zu
produzieren Dienstleistungen anzubieten
die Gesellschaft voranzubringen es ist
nicht nur eine Maschine die Geld
produziert und Geld verdient es ist auch
eine Verantwortung gegenüber dem Gebiet
und der Gesellschaft
die Menschen können diese Geschichte von
Steuerhinterziehung nicht mehr ertragen
auf Kundgebungen hört man regelmäßig von
Steuerparadiesen und Steuerhinterziehung
die Menschen wollen dass wir dieses
Problem wirklich an der Wurzel packen
drei Fußballfelder groß
330.000 Kubikmeter ohne Logos oder
Schilder
das ist die Erweiterung des Gucci Lagers
in St Antonino was ist die Funktion des
größten Gebäudes im Kanton Tessin jeden
Tag 365 Tage im Jahr kommen 50.000 waren
die bereits für die gesamte Produktion
von Gucci und anderen clearing Marken
fertiggestellt wurden mit Lastwagen in
diesen Lager an werden eingelagert in
Kisten umgepackt und verlassen es wieder
was passiert eigentlich in dieser kurzen
Zeit in Tessin die Rechnungen werden
gedruckt und Luxusprodukte made in Italy
werden vom Tessin aus in die ganze Welt
verkauft
indem man auch auf die
Verrechnungspreise spielt den Verkauf
der Ware die von den Lieferanten zu
einem Preis nahe dem Produktionspreis
kommt und zu einem Preis nahe dem der
Designerläden ausgeht bedeutet das für
Luxusgüter riesige Margen und ermöglicht
so die Realisierung sensationelle
Gewinne im Tessin aber ist die Logistik
eine Funktion die sie rechtfertigt
ihr Job ist im Grunde die Logistik ja
das ist richtig sind die Gehälter gut
nicht so ganz also teils und sind sie
hier ansässig nein in Italien sie sind
Italiener in Italien darf ich Sie fragen
wie groß die Gehaltsspanne ist sie
meinen je nachdem wie viele Stunden wir
leisten sie werden nach Stunden bezahlt
ja bei der Agentur wird noch Stunden
abgerechnet und der Stundensatz liegt
bei so in etwa wir bekommen etwa 17
Franken pro Stunde 17 Franken pro Stunde
ja es ist alles auf Analyse aufgebaut
denn im Grunde handelt es sich um ein
Unternehmen dass sich mit Logistik
befasst während man viele Jahre lang
vorgab es sei ein Unternehmen das alle
seine wichtigsten Funktionen hier
konzentriert hat Logistik ist keine
Hauptfunktion
die Logistik hat warum kommt die
Logistik in die Schweiz
ihre Präsenz in der Schweiz zu
rechtfertigen die Ansiedlung der
Logistik in der Schweiz war notwendig um
die Rolle von lgi zu etablieren und zu
rechtfertigen kehring hat sich bisher
immer für den Warentransport durch die
Schweiz eingesetzt die Logistik in der
Schweiz ist ein extra Schritt aus
steuerlichen Gründen und so ein extra
Schritt ist immer schädliches gehen
Liefertage verloren es gibt eine
Verdopplung der Kosten und das sind
alles kosten die von einem
steuerkreislauf diktiert werden den wir
sehr wohl vermeiden könnten wenn die
Schweiz die aus betrieblicher Sicht
ineffizient ist keinen Steuervorteil
mehr zulässt nun dann ist es
sinnlose operativer nun konzentrieren
warum beschloss die Gruppe ihr eigenes
Lager in St Antonino einzurichten
als die Gruppe beschloss ihr eigenes
Lagerhaus zu bauen suchte sie lange nach
einem Grundstück dieser Größe die Gruppe
wollte sich ursprünglich nicht in Sant
Antonino niederlassen sondern auf einem
Grundstück näher an der italienischen
Grenze es machte keinen Sinn die
Lastwagen in das supracenery fahren zu
lassen um eine Fahrt zu unternehmen die
ohnehin nutzlos und teuer war außerdem
handelte es sich um ein problematisches
Grundstück des verbessert werden musste
außerdem war der Multiplikator entsand
Antonino vor der Ankunft von Gucci hoch
wir kommen nicht mit einem so hohen
Multiplikator aber mit unserem Projekt
werden sie in senken können weil wir
Ihnen eine Menge Geld geben werden es
gab eine Diskussion mit Vita über die
präventive Senkung des Multiplikators
und der war dem Unternehmen eine große
Hilfe der Multiplikator aus dem Jahr
2010 vier Jahre vor der Ankunft von
Gucci zu Beginn der Verhandlungen wurde
schrittweise um 15 Punkte gesenkt und
viel auf 65% im Jahr 2014 dem Jahr in
dem das Lager gebaut wurde der
Multiplikator soll nun wieder steigen da
der Konzern die Stadt verlässt und gerne
an die Stadtverwaltung gezahlten
Einnahmen um mehr als die Hälfte sinken
wie rechtfertigen Sie diese Änderung der
Einnahmen
dass die Gewinne die bisher vollständig
im Tessin besteuert wurden nun aufgrund
einer unternehmenspolitischen Regelung
dort besteuert werden wo das Produkt
hergestellt wird und dort wo es
weiterverarbeitet wird
ein derartiges Lagerhaus in ihrem Gebiet
zu haben
erinnern sie zunächst einmal möchte ich
sagen dass die Bezeichnung Lagerhaus für
diese Anlage die im Wert von mehreren 10
Millionen Schweizer Franken gebaut wurde
etwas zu kurz gegriffen ist die
Lastwagen mit den Waren kommen da
jedenfalls an die waren kommen an und
von dort aus werden sie sortiert
die meisten Menschen die dort arbeiten
sind Lagerarbeiter die Magazine
zum größten Teil ja welche Vorteile
bringt und brachte dieses Unternehmen
dem Gebet
Video im allgemeinen brachte es dem
Gebiet vor allem den Vorteil einen
großen Teil des Industriegebiets und der
wirtschaftlichen Ressourcen neu zu
entwickeln Ressourcen die dann in Form
von Dienstleistungen an die Bevölkerung
weitergegeben werden
wir wissen gibt es 200 Arbeitsplätze von
denen ein kleiner Teil von Einheimischen
besetzt ist
sie eine Ahnung welche Art von Gehältern
im Durchschnitt angeboten werden
ich habe keine Ahnung wie viel sie
angeboten haben
macht ihnen die Vorstellung Angst dass
das Unternehmen eines Tages für immer
weggehen und dieses Gebäude leerstehen
könnte
diese Gruppen können wie wir wissen
gehen sich reformieren und umziehen ohne
jemanden fragen zu müssen denn es ist
ihre Entscheidung das zu tun
[Musik]
die neue Anlage in dem Lager in
rehacinho wurde offiziell von lgi
angekündigt aber ist es wirklich eine
Erweiterung oder ist es nur eine
Bestätigung dessen dass sie sich nur in
kleineren Lagern organisieren um die
Logistik komplett abzubauen
maximale Diskretion von dem Unternehmen
das seit Jahren der größte Steuerzahler
im Kanton ist scheint man nicht einmal
den Namen aussprechen zu können
wir wollten uns lediglich danach
erkundigen ob das Lager hier in der
Hauptsitz ist
ich weiß nichts darüber ich weiß
wirklich nichts
sie haben einen Pullover auf dem
luxusgüterlogistik steht ein guter
Freund von mir hat ihn mir geschenkt
aber sie arbeiten hier ja aber nicht für
das Unternehmen dass sie gerade erwähnt
haben Luxusgüter richtig ja ich arbeite
nicht für Sie wir können dazu nichts
sagen tut mir leid aber für wen arbeiten
sie
ich habe keine Ahnung ich bin nicht von
hier
ich finde es seltsam dass man nicht
sagen kann für wen man arbeitet das
haben sie uns gesagt nichts zu sagen ja
das haben sie uns gesagt
das Unternehmen hat sich nicht zu den
möglichen Änderungen in der Logistik
geäußert sicher ist dass in Tessin
vorerst nur Lastwagen und Kisten
verbleiben ohne den Vorteil von
Steuereinnahmen
[Musik]